you
hello folks happy Tuesday everything is
Tuesday yep
Brigitta is out we are currently trying
to download I thought it was gonna do
something faster it's fetching I just
want everyone to know that we're not
liars me and Joey here where is it
fetching there we go
so go out and get Brigitta I think that
she should be on console as well I don't
know if it'll be like right this minute
they're always pretty good about it on
PC available at 11:00 but I will have my
informants outside tell me if it's out
also you and the chat can tell us if
it's out thank you guys all for tuning
in what's up the Dragons me no banana
Moo ha turkey the game is updating yes
all right now playable the game is
launching now the question is will we
crash later and get stuck in queue oh I
don't know did that happen last time
maybe not on launch lunch now here's a
question of what are we doing in terms
of gameplay it's a good question are we
going Ark up she's available Squire to
Reinhard Brigitta depends our allies
with shield protect some with healing
and armor awesome support hero awesome
she's like a support hybrid man come on
she's like a semi tank yeah so do we go
through
oh yeah last time when we did the we
didn't do that super go through this
game's let's do it so we got her classic
yellow
blah this is swedish swedish is kind of
interesting because it's the the way
that it's spoken is so close to english
I don't even want to get into the naming
argument we could go down a long rabbit
hole and I don't want to KH 9 6 3 says
downloading on Xbox cool some people
saying not on console yet what I would
say is if you're on console or were on
console I would like turn it like reset
your your console and then kind of like
hope that it updates after that I like
the iron clad for 250 yeah I know it's
pretty pretty solid
I wonder if the mask comes down Python
huh yeah probably stays up anyway
dang what a baller one might can baller
what a baller mechanic and then this one
I like that one more like the crusader
armor oh that's so I had the my that one
I think I'm gonna play it but play her
that one look at this guy he doesn't
care he's just throwing his coins no
problem all right what do we got here
yeah see you later sketchy
repair that yep still good come at me
the worst gamer pyrius is downloading on
Xbox as we speak awesome awesome thank
you all for tuning in as we check out
brigita now that she's live on the non
public test realm which means console
we'll finally get a chance of player
here our highlight interest the one that
you said is the only good one that's my
opinion you can tell me if you agree
like I do like the flail one I think
it's like it I just feel like I see that
with so many of the other yeah you know
and that's fine I just feel like the
most work went into that first one cuz
like you know she looks back at the
first one and like has like the camera
and everything yeah it's like hi can I
help you oh the gold weapon oh I think I
did last time you okay yeah big gold
nice sweet is she out that at the moment
as George sign yes on PC we are playing
on PC we downloaded her right at 11 a.m.
and then apparently some people on Xbox
are saying it's on Xbox - we're gonna
play 66 no limits cuz that's probably
the only way we're gonna get freaky 'te
which also means that we're all pretty
much only gonna get probably 6 v6
brigita but that's fine it is what it is
we'll try to play some real matches
later and see if we can get breeki tough
but my guess is she's gonna get taken I
was able to during the PTR I was able to
actually get a couple
the matches are just with QuickPlay
uh-huh it really depends on what time or
how soon you get into the game yeah like
if you can like be the first one to pay
yeah metal gear there was an update so
if you are looking to try to play the
new here new support here Brigitta you
need to update definitely on PC and
definitely probably on console a lot of
people say not on ps4 yet so keep trying
and I'm sure I'll get word from the
folks outside once we get word that you
know she's out on console 2 or on ps4
too but yeah thank you all for tuning in
let's let's see what uh we can do today
well it's like they fix that a shield
bug during the the emo oh yeah did we go
our team frozen farts during great news
Rattlers asked asking are you guys gonna
talk about how competitive is missing on
console mmm-hmm no is it you don't know
he says how comp is missing on consoles
I assume competitive yeah unfortunately
I don't I haven't really played too much
on console outside like the one time I
was at a friend's house he was playing I
was like I wonder what it feels like to
play on console you know control weird
weird and it works it's fine you know
just that if you're used to a certain
way of playing a game it's it's
definitely weird it's just like if I
decided to play like fortnight or
something on console or on board oh no I
already did that I really did fortnight
mobile I am funky mobile that's an
experience I would say if you want to
feel good about yourself in pub key play
pub G mobile because if you're like
halfway decent you're probably going to
get some kills that's kind of what
happened - I guess what like Nick and
making them beautiful input D when it
came out on xbox
oh yeah yeah like the first couple of
days or whatever it got likes I can like
for whatever reason I I've played enough
console shooters where I feel decent at
console shooters and like even if it's
pub G or something like that that's
slightly different in terms of gameplay
like I still feel confident in aiming
with my thumb yeah so like I the first
time I played puppy on Xbox one I ended
up getting like six kills and almost
like was top ten like no problem so it's
the kind of the same with mobile right
now like John we've got like three top
fives I think yeah so nice all real
games and he's like I'm not even that
great at I poked you to be honest all
right here we go the six people in here
of course it's also when asking the chat
is the Hanzo patch out yet not yeah or
changes out yet yeah they're planning on
doing a PTR soon sometime I think they
said sometime in April so yeah he's
gonna be
a little bit yeah also if you guys want
a more in-depth guide of brigita
Joey put out brigita hero guide in our
kind of long-standing series of
overwatch heroes he's kind of champion
them now gone gone by this games like
two years old so surprisingly I keep
like thank you forget you're getting
that's been that long because they have
so many updates and events but yeah
that's out in the wild game spot as well
as YouTube check that out if you want to
but we can quickly also kind of
breakdown something like you why don't
you break down some of your skills
alright so we got we got six big eats is
on the payload here all with their own
personal shield and so you can you can
tell right away she's kind of like you
know like a little mini Reinhardt right
here with her with her shield yeah it
doesn't like she she is a healer but she
can take a good amount of damage she has
250 HP which is I think the most and
then the rally gives you armor as well
as the yeah one ability where if you're
like full life it gives you more armor
yeah so so her healing abilities are her
inspire which is like a passive heal
every time you melee and like heels
maybe for like I think it was 30 health
over a couple seconds and then she has
like a little armor packs that she can
toss out her allies so I'm doing here
speaking of mobile games Joey did you
see that there's a Dragon Ball mobile
game oh yes I even looked at yet I saw
the update it's out yet so I got a lot
of health I have five 475
no coming this summer
Thank You anvil one of our own Joey's
guide oh that was nice oh she's hiding
now
yeah get out of here I was gonna say a
lot of people last time we streamed this
during the PTR we're seeing far as a
pretty yeah I think I was like she can't
reach from all the way down here but you
can't tilt your shield though yeah you
can wear a made-up words down okay Lucy
oh what a hipster got that nice done yes
so she has a little shield bash thing Oh
No
dead is skulk she is live on PC some
people were saying she was live on Xbox
not on ps4 yet according to some people
but yeah Vitara unfortunately I don't
understand Swedish so I can't say I wow
this dead chat persons angry Jesus
thunder bang that person is upset so I
just wanna play freaky tail
why are you playing Faro man Lindsay
does gaming unfortunately I'm not sure
if other than that smoothie people that
have said that she's in on xbox I
haven't seen anything in Olmo ago in
regards to her so on ps4 yet do you know
the somme Brandner is in no yeah no yeah
I don't think they've discussed much
about other than the fact that they want
to kind of tone them down a little bit
so apparently that's rally to me right
is that what's yeah stay away oh my god
I don't think Winston's the answer but
alright I'm gonna wait for my team
someone the last time was saying maybe
Reaper seemed okay I feel like I was
able to 1v1 a Reaper pretty good but
could just beat PTR so alright let's
push on three goes on that and that's
Erick yellow is Joey mentioned we don't
think of the somber nerf is in yet nor
is the Honjo change without that was
that multi shot yeah the Hanzo still
hasn't won hasn't landed just because
soul Mon hasn't even landed in PTR yet
oh my goodness well there's a Reaper
don't even bother blocking right like
they're all blocking you should just be
swinging yeah because there's no point
cuz it doesn't block I will need to
bring up the shield that has a pair of
these for the bash yeah but come on time
to go ham
mumumu may says not live on ps4 with
like a multiple cores yet he goes yeah
at least we have a tank that's good
there's a Reaper so someone is trying it
definitely but the knock-back definitely
I'm getting out here come on take out
Sleepy Hollow yeah that knows him he's
like trying to do like a anti brigitta
video don't crack counter that's yeah
junk rat seemed pretty good jumper out
yeah that was tough to deal with for
sure
but again this is not a good
representation always second at 20
player kill Street probably
Lindsay some people were saying she was
out on xbox what I would do is try
resetting your xbox is and then seeing
if that gets you the update you should
get an update before you're able to play
as a precursor rid of that guy come on
guys push the payload oh really yeah I
think an inner up Ultimates and a whole
bunch of cool stuff yeah finally
six-night not sirak ello says ps4 just
got the update hope you're you're
telling the truth there but if they are
in fact telling truth go on PlayStation
reset your PlayStation and see if you
got that update for brigita you'll be
the first time console players will get
a chance to player Oh
Roadhog go enjoy your doing in a soldier
no people are tryharding now what do you
think you're gonna be doing playing no
limits here come on no you know what you
get yourself into oh no no that guy's a
song bro thank you for patch is lives as
pokies gaming thank you thank you all
for all that info we appreciate it
I'm telling the truth 985 megabyte
update thank you
sorry I just seems too much hole always
caution that I can't always trust check
that chat usually has my back but
sometimes yeah some cases they find ways
to trick me you know I've been tricked a
couple times right you know but it's
okay
patch not live in Ireland though for ps4
says Jamie Baxter but on Sweden this one
trick mercy main says I'll check for ps4
restarting now reminds me a lot of d3
crusader yes Stephen McCowen that's one
of the first things I said I will best
do that I was like okay flail yup shield
yup tank healer yep yeah and like you
know you get in the way even the alt
kind of reminds me of Crusader in a way
because it's like like you know like
giving the aura yeah and that's like a
like another Crusader buff so no I mean
like all Blizzard property so you know I
kind of in a way is cool because some
people are saying like it could help
like the anti dive comps because it's
like that right you got we need three
three biggie to shields in order to you
cover Reinhardt uh-oh there's a widow
and a junk rat here we go here comes the
serious counter meta there's a bear trap
there okay so I'm good it's fine
attack oh my god
I'm outta here oh good
no did you have no shield shield watch
that it's live in Mexico me amigo thank
you go sleep I yep as digital has
mentioned it's on PC as well as being
told both other both other platforms
both consoles what I would do if you're
not seeing the update is to reset either
the Blizzard launcher or reset your
consoles respectively and then turn that
back on and you should see the update
what's your main account rank guys says
J saw well this is Joey's account he's
what platinum 52 for for Platinum's and
a 52 for star whatever that however that
works out all right talking about calm
oh maybe comp yeah what's your comp
remember I like gold somewhere bad I
never got into calm it made me rage II
like it reminded me of playing dota
again yeah I mean it's like when it when
you have good teams they're really good
but then it's like it's just more
extreme version of like quick play yeah
like well I don't know with quick play
either I just didn't notice it maybe
because I didn't care as much but it
like comp just felt more like a time
sink yeah then quick play because like
did your grind you know get out and like
the matches feel longer oh no they are
longer okay so like I don't know I just
it kind of ruined it for me because it
felt like like I said it felt like DOTA
dota2 again where you know I could spend
40 minutes on a match that I knew I was
gonna lose yeah and like that sucks but
that's what it is
old man Tate on like sweaty matches yeah
I don't like sweaty matches anymore I'm
a casual gamer now I play single-player
games
Felix Ford says oh god 50 my 59 minutes
left yeah that's unfortunate
comp makes everyone raging yeah
I think some people handle it better
than others I think solo players playing
comp probably get rayji because that's
tough
yeah fine when you're trying to get to
the next like level I've had friends
kind of just get upset
so actually why don't we do deathmatch
alright do its try that shake oh we
already probably I think you're gonna
get killed or someone's gonna pick her
right before you can well you can you
can have it harmony at ready-1
it's just free throw I'm gonna get rekt
go Manny switch your armor see don't let
that hot yeah there we go
crusader full-on crusader right now
stephen McCone look at us good feeling
about this oh did it end up working for
you uh miss one trick mercy main I would
assume so yeah 980 5.0 wearing update
says Barry Allen 90 second left for Tony
Konami to play sweet
but someone else is playing Preakness
this is like a proper Geeta
that's hilarious it is oh oh shoot there
- get out of here other person and still
got them man but I remember no you
didn't get it they got it
well I think it was shared though
because I like dying I thought it was
whoever got it laughs you get assists -
so I got one kill once this Hey so mom
is the worst yeah yeah it's tough all
right I'm in fourth place
nice let me play other person get out of
here they're gonna steal your kill man
oh you're dead you're so dead um no I
feel like it's kind of hard to outplay
people with brigita okay so like there's
not love Amy no obviously no you Juke
the the when you shield bashed and
stunned yeah they thought that you were
gonna stay in place so you can't out
play that way true yeah yeah just stay
out of their millions what I was gonna
ask you it's like you know how like
sometimes you fight a road hog the road
hog right it's like you don't want to be
the first one that hook right yeah oh oh
here we go oh it's done it doesn't
matter go ham I'll get all three and the
tracer oh yeah all right run get that do
you know if sombras had to I forgot we
tested it do you know sombras hack does
anything to her passive healing oh the
passive no that one doesn't give me a
chance
oh I was way cool no didn't we figure
out what was the combo it was like swing
swing stun swing and then lay out the
flail yeah that's if they stand still
though oh you can get that common lost
oh there's one tracer that's trihard
he's just running through everything
okay let's stay away from road hog
because I would not I'm not gonna be
able to kill him is everyone
woohoo I got a ps4 UK says Scott
February nice McCree is probably someone
was saying doofus too as a oh oh here
comes the real hard counter oh so far
away
you got a triple off them did you just
kill that guy yeah I did well he respawn
probably right there yeah look at that
spot the eggs
that's why play the game talk to ya
[Music]
bunny moto when you have no space left
to download I know
feeling I always wonder why mic things
not downloading and it's because I'm out
of space
are you dead you got pinched as nervous
he says yeah if you're out of space you
can just uninstall like another
application a game that you don't play
too much is usually what I end up doing
oh this is an interesting matchup here
you can hear I think right
oh you wasted it to it it sucks
feels bad man feels bad top four at
least come on Ashley evergreen I
literally cannot wait any longer
oh yeah I hit a wall that's why I think
there's so much damage but it's is still
kind of broken like a punch
yeah like it rock there's a lot of bugs
with it far as as far as it like sending
people back into walls goes sometimes it
does sometimes it just completely misses
almost gone wrong dammit
they never did say why she's so tall
right relative to your payment I mean I
guess she gets it from her mom yeah it's
possible
cuz like my brother is pretty tall and
my stepdads pretty short he's like
probably like five five two five five
one five two my dad's probably like 510
511 but my mom's pretty tall
so yeah it's probably let's clean that
up
oh you got flashed right and yeah yeah
you can't do anything
oh I like it these were just waiting to
stun you probably own oh okay oh yeah
you gotta get away you better get away
doom fist what you're gonna do yeah
rising uppercut us we're not afraid
well I heard the Makri die somewhere oh
whoa
so does your basically knew nothing in
this moment probably yeah pretty
relatives what oh what a silly silly
goose I kill - come on man we were gonna
stop the High Noon I don't even know why
he high noon there seems like you
probably just yeah he just panicked what
though oh you want her a little rematch
or a rematch oh yeah it gets killed oh
you're good not dead yet
oh man that's pretty good I think you
might have had a chance of your 1 be
winning but it's like that hoes in first
place though Oh deep I hate to tell you
but your brother guy is - the mailman
it's possible probably not though good
joke mark good joke
[Music]
going yeah and he was number one Papa
freakness Oh your clothes you're only
three kills behind yeah this is actually
pretty pretty fun oh you try to sneak up
okay not gonna be there up you got one
oh you got yeah
I hope my ps4 is lying I have to wait 12
hours to play freakin so why because
you're down wasn't it 812 hours
haha Oh side bus it's all about side bus
here okay I need to lease Barry Allen
says I'm Zen and rhein-main so I think
she's my new main it see you see that
missed it so the slugger was a just like
the folks on me I need to not lose to
cold star that's the Makri what's that I
heard someone this is gonna be fun where
did where did he come from Preet this
switching characters left and right gang
or do you even get it oh you did I mean
as in that guy's dead and then this
person is dead - OH
get rekt I'm a crusader with full full
set armour top for at least up for it's
up water I'll take it
Oh Oh wasn't the Makri then what how
what could she have possibly done here
oh she's - she did you kill the road hog
okay unless it killed one more after
this right yeah oh maybe
what what I don't know
the Mercurio get a triple oh man
12 hours I don't that's unfortunate
little long
if I get one kill in the road Brigitta
she'll become my new main yeah I can't
be too hard to do that right I'm gonna
try quick play something good something
good well at least is all new because
yeah it's her so she's a cat person
apparently she has a lot of a cat's
praise gimme gimme gimme gimme
dammit I was like one I was like half a
second too short okay sigh okay
well go hit Graham the Godfather yeah so
like Brigitta is really good at being
just like in the front lines with
someone like Reinhardt or she can like
swing around with him yeah spare keep me
alive I'm in school mmm no comments just
not gonna stay in school anyone else
have a twenty four point seven point
five seven gigabyte update you probably
just haven't updated in a while as my
guess yes he way proven she does heal as
[ __ ] is Russia yeah as bunny moto
mentioned the update for just Brigitta
assuming you're up-to-date prior to
today there's only about nine hundred
eighty five ish megabytes less than a
gig
let's go got that young Reinhard skin
huh yeah I was pretty good it's so good
if the arm right I bought the anime I'm
anime Reinhardt oh the green one
yeah like the that is no that's is a all
Brigitta what it is buddy yeah that was
his mental yeah Thank You Steven me for
spamming get good four times weirdo have
we heard any of the alike
was there any voice the was there I
haven't heard any yet I'm pretty sure
there is like if you picked yours or
what yeah I can imagine there would be
there's a fara guys tire Oh God we got
the triple shield comp here we got
Theresa Reinhardt and Brigitta oh you
could have got like to know there was a
long time in there yeah
oh they all did come on guys just sniper
my pcs pretty old now granted I have
like a 980 in it now but it runs
overwatch surprisingly why my computer
is like five years old
yeah overwatch is just ones games that
can run on anything almost this way
sure saying it won't make the potato
mode show oh it will add some oh it they
actually patched out some things that
that made it look worse okay mostly
because it's since it is competitive
shooter it would get rid of like foliage
and stuff when I reference potato mode
it's a new show that Joey's been working
on one episodes out it's basically
taking some of the most beautiful
looking games that you can think of and
going the polar opposite and making it
as horrible looking or more horrible
than you think
as as if it was being played on potato
oh God so the first episodes out and it
was a GTA should check that out it's
pretty funny it's on GameSpot and
YouTube so whichever you prefer platform
is check that out
what did you put in oh [ __ ]
Oh want to come in here oh god is he
selling there oh that sucks
oh you could have shattered yeah waiting
for the recipient yield come on Kerrigan
do something something care about the
fara you're supposed to be taking care
of this what we would never run yeah so
there would be another potato mode out
this Friday Friday right yeah
later actually ever get any thanks for
stopping my appreciate it
overwatch potato mow would be
interesting to see can't wait to see the
characters in n64 mode yeah be a couple
probably like a little bit from there
from now but uh have you said what
you're doing next I'm gonna be doing
next episode B Kingdom Come deliverance
so get ready for some Kingdom Come
deliverance played on a potato come
Friday
Harvey Alan I love your vids guys keep
up the good work thank you for the kind
words and you we appreciate it obviously
it's not I'll try to send that message
over to the rest of the team as well we
appreciate it though thank you
I tell ya as someone mentioned Pacific
Rim is coming out this week got to go
check that out
what's a micro Joe might have put it out
his review I'm not 100% positive that or
at least his impressions
someone take care of this Farah kind of
excited hopefully it's good oh you're so
oh my oh it was the Brigitta but then
she died
sweet what's up for Ricci Omar says the
team comp sucks
yeah it's not that great not very good
oh hey what you gonna do
there's no going back the other way oh
[ __ ]
you finally paid you back you know
because you only have one healer and
it's a brigita yeah yeah because there's
something to do with it I got the two
healer comp they have a Moira which we
could definitely use look at this oh he
wanted it uh-oh was that theirs
yeah I was totally this oh she's still
alive because she has so much armor
could have shattered oh I should've you
know I was tough you might have wasted
it though because I don't think you got
follow-up see if you use review look at
what they're doing do is you Marcel um I
think that oh gosh it won't come out
till later this this week
they just started playing yesterday and
they probably want to get a good feel of
you know what the game has and want to
give you the best review possible so I'm
guessing later this week for the CFDs
review maybe early next week but yeah
they started playing our I think Peters
reviewing it and he started playing it
yesterday like later in the day so
alright either end of this week or early
next the objective oh you see that same
time except for some reason I got
knocked down he went in the air
hey guys even contesting it yeah we are
I just I just do not want a bit going up
their percentage is going up all crap
no now you weren't actively rip that was
a hardy rip rip arrow knees pepperoni so
that wouldn't have happened if I was
brigita oh you got out Ryan hearted see
anime Ryan oh but no this is wearing a
church
with that but yeah yeah where's my taco
that's a good question
also have you guys didn't know GDC is
happening this week we've got some
different things lined up so stay tuned
for that stuff well yeah also if you
guys were interested in see if these
were the people asking if he wanted to
see what the Kraken actually looks like
gameplay-wise we somehow got lucky and
ran into the Kraken yesterday that was
pretty good so we put up cracking
gameplay nick was because losing his
mind is - is the right term oh wait so
the software nerf is yeah is it hold on
let me see I can check the patch notes
robots are you with your overwatch
gaming experience the other big changes
in this update involve sombras Sombra
who's being nerved that this is from our
Chris Pereira oh so what is it Blizzard
is addressing frustrations with her by
putting hack on a 2 second cooldown when
it's interrupted by damage additionally
the game should now deal with her her
line of sight being broken while casting
hack we're also removing the point 1
second window of time during a hack
where it could be where it couldn't be
canceled via line of sight or other
abilities included in tracers recall and
saria's particle barrier which was
originally put in place so the hack
wouldn't be interrupted by small objects
this was like what was we have a gold
look at that portrait right there next
to mine never seen that color below
he must have played he must be playing a
lot not just at 3 no but it's gold and
silver oh I get it I get you now that's
a holy Sh
rainbow Chi I don't want to say I will
say now that I think about a thousand is
not that much for one character then he
had yeah he had a bunch of to hundreds
he has total 2500 hours because I think
if I look at my Diablo 3 which I hate
looking at I have like my monk alone has
like a thousand plus hours or destiny
one that's not here I can see you'll
you'll have to check it on destiny
there's a website those a website for
that wasted on destiny to here I'll tell
you destiny to well it's not as much
right ah
you'd be surprised it's definitely not
as much though because it's like it's
not it hasn't been as long can't climb
right now oh wow oh this destiny one
okay how much do you think I've played
mmm it's over a thousand okay I will say
1200 okay according to this my destiny
one waste the time wasted on destiny one
was in terms of played 15 22 1520 two
hours was wasted wasted what would you
mean idle
I don't know so wasted I think the one
hundred seventy eight hours is my
deleted other oh so I had two Titans at
one point and then I decided to have one
of each so there's that I could have
sworn there was a time wasting on
destiny to to but let me see
yeah it's not the same website anyway
from her a lot of time man a lot of time
spent same with Diablo poppy pretty
gross that's a lot of Symetra yeah
that's a lot of semester oh yeah oh okay
I probably shouldn't be all the way out
here hitting him
Bob Jones Lane is 219 is SCT I'm gonna
stay next to the Brigitta yeah give me
the armored brigade this can be kind of
tough when you're being like pushed back
like this because she needs to get in
and like in order to melee yeah they get
the heels yeah other thing she's not
gonna be able to heal at all yeah side
for now armor pack oh there's my destiny
- oh it's not that bad
surprisingly 310 on destiny - almost had
look and 51 hours of deleted on destiny
- bye oh oh oh and then have 64 hours on
PC - so like 400 later Harvey Allen
thanks for stopping by
useful trails rally heal trout Sombra a
little bit later
oh the hacks yeah I can see what they
chained that hack on did you did you
confirm in the patch answer out of
curiosity I haven't checked it yet yeah
take that doughnut see you
oh she's trying the hacks I know it's
here oh this is the one man Genji yeah
okay get stunned to use it no pairs got
500 hours in Wow I don't want to look at
my wow there's so much time I spend
yelling and like ogre Mar and like
Stormwind just jumping on a mailbox in
college that 25 is there a site that
lets you see that nowadays well I'm sure
there is there has to be I'm wasted on a
world of warcraft one more wait well I
mean yeah they keep it in game so yeah
but I know I wouldn't be able to I want
to be able to check it outside of oh you
stupid Sombra is there way outside of
the game hmm maybe like a ton like a
counter yeah like how time waste our
destiny it just pulls the feed from
somewhere you know and I mean and then
like I mean if I can track my Blizzard
plate or my PC play through on Blizzard
I don't know why I would be able to see
my my Wow time to you
Nicholas says that guy with that gold
and silver border is platinum which
means he is over level 1800 Jesus okay
that's a lot of play time that is quite
a bit
oh and increased solo mm-hmm you're also
solo Oh Brigitta oh he'll thank you I
got sniped into the but right after I
have that help that I would see my oh
hey counter that with your sword well
some catch it actually actually
deflected one last weekend so I just
jumped over Kerrigan you're in the wrong
game
therefore keep that oh she's all the way
uh no no worries uh miss one trick mercy
main thanks enjoy watch a markiplier and
drink some was iced tea yeah I'm curious
to know like much for a while so I'm
sure I have okay thousand hours as well
it is idling like oh oh
horse drivers GeForce driver someone
rally to the flag well she stunned me
out of my deflect maybe I'll wait killed
three of us dead no so dead it's a swing
maybe we'll junk it let's just chug it I
kill them oh you did yeah looking good
that's no we're fine we're fine my one
regret is not getting ya is that getting
police officer Deva though she's still
in there though I didn't have to play
here as a storm right no you don't like
Africa by it yeah so it's like just a
regular legendary now if I I could've
got it for free yeah but now that that
window has passed they were a lot there
so I feel like there haven't been any
skins that have been just a one and done
like every single skin has come back in
some in some way
whoa where'd he go
oh that's
I get that high ground huh yeah well
Kobe I'll fade away
Kobe
I need to heal where is everybody
he gave up
hiding
oh my god yeah go come on it looks like
nobody had their shield up any
stragglers uh-uh
the creek Dan that was pretty good
I thought you were gonna get like oh
like almost whole team though
good old junk rat skill book come on
threes and why is used in in overwatch
League cuz he's good he's pretty he
hasn't only has high damage output got
on it he's gonna get hacked get her nice
we're good yeah what's up its Lobo how
are you doing Danny no bread that's
awesome yeah she is available guys on
all five no more no more having to wait
oh this is it at the end I think Oh
I'm not sure whose team that was other
team yeah hey you guys been watching the
overwatch League I have not been
watching that much I didn't want I've
been catching the san francisco games
every so often maybe so suck uh I think
not I want to say suck it's just not
definitely not in the top four of teams
somewhere they're 12
okay so we're in the middle we're
somewhere in the middle lower lower
lower of the six we're not we're not
Shanghai if that with your eyes you
can't use that as the the metric that
there's like one horror will tell you
that you can cause if you say everything
for the average team I want to say maybe
Florida or Florida or Houston somewhere
in the middle mm-hmm maybe Houston might
be near the top but top ones are
definitely like Seoul London I think one
of the LA yeah London the team with
full-on Koreans I'm telling you man
that's it's how San Francisco signed
their first Korean this week and oh and
Sinatra's turning 18 this month so he's
gonna finally join the team he's
eligible yeah
we've been we've been hiding this talent
okay Rita got will lead us to victory
[Music]
just get her oh nice ok sorry I was like
distracted by our slack channel this is
a good team go to Winston Winston
all right yeah okay so I mean it's it's
fine I mean there's like rival sites and
stuff like that so you're a gamer right
they I think they got it like kind of
like a fresh you put a paint on their
website yeah and EA UK it was like oh
yeah it looks good looks sharp and they
Eurogamer responds it looks better with
adblock who responded he said hey you're
okay okay so EA send out a tweet to your
gamer saying like hey your website Oh
with the screenshot yeah with the
screenshot man Eurogamer responded like
it looks actually better without adblock
on but yeah anyways figure I keep you
guys in the loop you know everyone
watching I'd like to think she looks
like a crusader to be honest but look up
d3 Crusader and you'll see what I'm
saying talk about maybe not the helm but
everything else
Yolo okay one thing about brigitta is
that she doesn't have like passive
healing like I got that male like mercy
or Lucio does gotta get in there so if
you get stuck with like half health and
like no one around you to protect you
you probably just go point Reapers going
in
yeah slap that reinhardt away oh this is
not good lucio where are you Oh Shh Oh
night Oh the counter where'd he go
I just abandoned I should I think you
should oh no you guys are good
he ran Oh get out of here
Oh almost more Oh Laura's not feeling
where I wanted to make sure that you
knew that can we go well we got the way
Stillman number we know in the back
blood junkie uh she is live Akrid TM
look at this mace
what's up legit gamer how you doing why
she is out on console to blame so if you
haven't gotten a chance to play Brigitta
you'll get your chance soon boo the
double the Lucio Brigitta double off we
need more DJ okay we're all here massive
shield here stay back going into they're
out healing
oh well Brigitta Brigitta got him tracer
and cases buying time not anymore
nice stop it spring my sweet spray I
haven't put any on you he's out on Xbox
I'm Pierce mark sweet oh they used
there's why
did he get someone oh no yeah he did he
got the widow oh oh she was on the
platform going out probably
he's like you'll never know Oh surprise
right heart Oh guys guys come here you
oh I got the tail end of that that's
silly
damn it ah let's go my hope though
damn I like barely gave right no yes so
much how the heck is going on
I do miss that yellowed the time yeah oh
that's alright
they still smashed her you block that
one the more you can write no it goes
through shields o gold gun McCree there
though
thanks for story I rice grease those
cheers love the Calvary's here hi hey
it's the beat'em now he's gonna come out
this way a man who's gonna die wow the
long time
stay close to the prison oh hey lads my
first time we machine what's up d mail
thanks for stopping by
appreciate it
we stream every day if you guys didn't
know Jenna usually at 11:00 a.m.
sometimes we like yesterday we had like
three streams those are very rare though
I usually try to have one today
sometimes there's two just depends on
the week there's a lot of stuff going on
this week Fridays probably gonna be a
double push the payload oh good I'm
gonna check out that new monster monster
hunter world we're gonna get to play a
game a little early on Friday I'm gonna
get to play another game a little early
on Thursday and I haven't decided what
I'm doing tomorrow yet which is a little
bit a problem but it's fine
stunlock this guy come on guys he didn't
charge you at that point but I guess you
didn't want to dive here Bob Genesis
it's nice to see a bunch of GS James
again yeah I mean it's late as mentioned
Bob every day stop that you're grown up
now oh yeah see so I figured it out head
cracking Oh Ted crack dang I thought it
was a Gundam iron orphanhood so her her
her for whip it goes just about as fast
as Road hogs hook so if you're like if
you need like timing yeah thanks ever
heard of paladin's its discount
overwatch widget overall I sugar-free
I've heard of it oh yeah
are we recording yes I am why is it oh
it was this guy right here is it because
at the downtown shot yes oh I got a
double kill here and then he dies
off-screen that's fine skill shots go
shot yeah oh yeah goals objective time
so always want to go for I always vote
for myself AB something that everyone
should do Stefano argue olace yes
streams everyday around 11 a.m.
usually 11 a.m. on the Monday to Friday
Pacific Standard Time
easy peasy says anonymous oh you want to
do some Sombra stuff oh yeah Laura well
I think you should keep gang brigita if
you can if I can keep the backup is
quick enough
Internet's fastened itch decent you
think that's faster I don't know it
depends on who you land on fine I'll go
summer so it's time for a got changes
according to Chris prayer one of our
news I love having this heroes logo
peppermint that is a nice quality of
life change for sure
Brian RDM we're reading primarily I read
twitch and YouTube chat a lot of this
stuff is coming in from from YouTube so
that's generally where the the chats
kind of popping off you're like surfing
Stoll up here okay
get these out of the way nobody likes
railings hack one use help thanks back
here actually lollipop yeah she's on
console and PC
out today updates already alive do you
feel any difference oh not yet okay is
that when you hack people please tell me
they'll have no limits available all
week I would say yeah they'll probably
do that I defer to Joey usually when the
character first comes out it's like just
the one give everyone like them
opportunity to do that how many things
how many help taxing you hack
oh shoot I didn't put that in the right
spot and somehow not dead
mercy Savior jeez I am please somewhere
in the wild
yes Amanda Derek vaquita is playable
there's one on the other team there's
one on our team too we're gonna go do
some hack and we're probably some
stealth like hacking Reaper has nowhere
to go right now cuz he is hacked that
burpees he's my kid yep SMG do we easily
do it's so good so according to the
patch notes it was like the UH there's
now a cool-down when she gets her hack
broken like before it used to be if if
she misses or if you if you damage her
she could just immediately do it right
away and that was kind of like like too
good
yeah that was pretty good how do you
have your hack oh sorry Symmetra
that is doing like nothing oh yeah I got
em all of them you just sprayed and
prayed tickle them a little oh so that's
yeah there's no cooldown right there
okay so it is in then cool I mean not
that I wouldn't trust Chris Ware but you
know at the same time it's like we
weren't sure cuz we didn't check the
patch notes ourselves we just thought it
was breeki to haze our United she is it
available go check her out
you know hack these health facts oh
sorry did you answer that how many can
you is it as many as you want or is
there a limit no I told you it's been a
while although they they they backed up
though you're like I'm not Oh watch out
can you teleport out no no no we're all
dead it's the team kill should I save
that hack I don't know if it would have
helped us they were all kind of that's
all over the place yeah so the hack
changes are in stone frost I can read
something I can read the actual notes if
you guys want specifics but uh pull that
up real quick
okay so addressing frustrations with her
by putting hack on a two second cooldown
when it's interrupted by damage Anderson
Lee the game should now deal with her
line of sight being broken while casting
hack also removing that 0.1 second
window of time during a hack where it
couldn't be canceled via LAN a site with
other abilities of doing fissures
recalls our particle barrier which is
originally put in place so that the hack
wouldn't be interrupted by small objects
such as light posts we've implemented a
separate fix for that issue so there you
go
Oh get I got made me all day baby I
gotta remember her like flow chart well
it's like okay hack hack hack a health
pack throw the teleporter down run in
invisible hack someone else oh god oh
god is part of the flowchart yeah you
can't use them about certain abilities
during the graviton surge and that was a
nasty wombo it was looking like you're
dominating them and yeah okay all of a
sudden like they just ii win
okay I'll go a little bit more thir if
you're asking about comp level Malcolm's
there I think he said he's like gold
rally to me
so is that rally des memes dank memes
baby never know where to go come on you
can't lose go he's pretty much playing
like connected harassing type character
oh so by the way scatter arrow is still
in the game yeah if y'all were curious
oh yeah good oh you have your hack at
least get it off yeah
[Music]
everyone's kind of dead yeah
take the achievement get multi hacks up
on me okay it's over yeah it's over it's
over now it's I'm still hopping around
Mercy's still trying her best
Oh completely miss damn it's great with
DES okay with ya awesome easy for me to
judge though because I'm clearly not
playing
gotta love backseat gaming it seems like
I've been able to get into the the
characters like pretty early it's just a
matter of me being on time gotta
increase your yeah bro any tips on
getting better on aiming um I don't have
any tips that I mean I just I would say
play more maybe try to figure out what
your best sensitivity yeah a sensitivity
has a lot to do with it like one thing I
notice that a lot of pros do they they
play with low sensitivity and like
gigantic mouse mats so they use their
entire forearm to move the mouse instead
of just the wrists
I don't know if I can get used to that
I'm very much like a wrist player
please Nair scatter isn't that coming
hasn't happened yet right no yeah rip
sombre again 2017-2018 gloomy let me get
one of her highlight intros gotta get
the fender you could have had that I
know I know you had purchased it early
I can't even one of these to really look
at ham spending gold cut what 10,000
Wilson we're gonna do that shoe but some
don't some skins cost 3,000 like the
special yeah the special ones but I mean
I feel like every time an event rolls
around I always have a stockpile that
just stays about the same because I get
open up the boxes
by way everyone's that I don't get and
then all the duplicates just add that up
as gold
arriving and then a nurse Sombra yes I
did Andrew I read some things already
but this is just a yeah who got her
first she is out on console Sirdar go
update mr. Jack's VEVO hey guys hope
you're having a great day yeah it's
pretty awesome day so far getting to
play brigita on what we do that and I
hope you're having a good day - yeah as
goddess nation nation has mentioned yeah
scare shot is gonna get taken away from
Hanzo you've seen what he's gonna get in
return right I did not know it was like
I think they have plans for one they're
gonna replace Kara shot with like a fast
firing like yeah like a rapid-fire shot
and then also give them a disengage so
he can like leap leap away if he needs
soon okay
it's like hunters from you know wow I
guess that works okay we're a hunt oh
yeah just yeah mani hunters in with
disengage you could go back pretty far
yeah you can kite a lot I don't know you
strafe during the strafe that's it you
know that's a Diablo skill right strafe
that one where you rapid-fire oh really
yeah I don't know if you can I don't
know it's not even in test but yeah like
rapid shot better than free one-shot
kills
yeah yeah more skill can we place as
Emmie we're just kind of going through
so probably not gonna team up probably
like one or two more matches and we're
probably to wrap up soon Wow okay if you
care about WWE wrestling generally
Daniel Bryan has been medically cleared
for action so I wouldn't be shocked if
he's gonna make it to Wrestlemania
WrestleMania yeah
I will protect you don't worry I'll get
this may
whoops is this better than fortnight
very different games
would they have a sniper
getting out of here if you can
Forbes baby well what you go uh-oh sorry
do have this quick you're still alive no
no no he oh did he
oh nice yeah yeah oh you have a tube but
I don't know if your team's there though
no but I want to survive this
oh there's what Wynnstay own baby
Oh - there's a bad guy Winston - yetiz
yetiz fighting yetis oh it's an angry
Yeti now the door closed on them then
alright cool
we good we good we've got a you've got
turd in a good spot too
ooh armored go play rainbow 60 Carboni
says uh yeah we got people that like
Rainbow six siege Michael Hardy one of
them I think Jake was playing a bunch of
ran with 62 themto Husker Deus in the UK
every day and loves a game yep
you're just gonna walk into it huh on
ps4 where she says Sean I would try
resetting your ps4 if you don't see the
update for she should be there though as
confirmed by a lot of people in chat and
Thank You Kat
took care of that Yeti no problem Oh is
she easy to play ass HPT pixels Oh easy
I mean she's I don't know I mean if
you're gonna if you're gonna go by
Blizzard's official ratings which they
have here you know she's one star as far
as difficulty goes because I would say
just a lot of her her her abilities are
somewhat straightforward you know like
shielding armor like there's only so
much you can do with like putting an
armor pack on somebody but her her
strengths just lie in just being able to
get in do damage and survive alongside
your tanks yeah I'm like this guy right
here Stephen Amell says to be iron it's
just watching because mine is Dowling
that's totally fair totally happy that
you're chillin till you're you can play
too
carlos strong asking which characters
you like to play most all go first
zen yatta and yes mayor reaper i don't
know about joey joe he's got his own
tastes been playing a lot more playing a
lot more Genji lately which is kind of
satisfying like once you get rolling
with him it's so much fun
guys I have my alt let's do is enjoy
playing black cats warrior judgment
thinks says her auto attack seems pretty
strong for a tanky support it still
takes a good amount like we were saying
the combo would be like swing swing
shield swing and then the on sale so
that's a good amount of stuff that you
got to do there to kill someone but yeah
you do heal though as you may Lane yes
and yeah the one tough part as Joey said
though blue cliff that was it I got her
cutie spray sweet see you later
Kerrigan oh you just destroyed that
brigita
model mall no it's live
Brigitta is live across all three
platforms PCE as well as console damn
Haywood gonna play her she's live on the
live servers she just attacked Moira's
healing
there's armor behind you - daddy's armor
daddy's armor Owens nice that was good
man I hope they would be sick if it was
just that one play but yeah I'll go get
it
that mental kill we just bought a
highlight intro come on Blizzard give me
something ah it's okay I get it happened
we know we've seen it I am recording
- what okay whatever I think it was the
dead cat fort which character was the
first overwatch hero you tried to play
at in the game oh that's from Stefano
first one I played sold that was that
Lisa what two and a half years ago I
don't remember I want to say was Lucio
or McCree that's probably one of those I
might have soldiered it I don't remember
the soldier was such a like that's a cod
that's a cotton right Mike Hawk says yo
I'm kind of man every time I get to pick
brigita my whole team leaves I would
just chill and wait right because they
got a they gotta fill out the rest of
its yeah she's out obvious board on to
army
kaito cam I don't think that'll actually
be how we get more people there onto
that platform but worth looking into
she looks Opie I don't know like you
still have to be able to get into the
the action yeah like your team is not
there with you like what are you really
doing yeah you're kind of walking her
heels I will say like her her her
passive heel is not a whole lot but like
the thing is you're gonna have to keep
being in like battle may Lane and the it
can be kind of risky especially if
you're with someone who doesn't have
like another shield for you to back up
into like right now I have a oh there we
go you know IRISA but if you're just
like with a road hog you might be kind
of hard because you can't protect you
nearly as well
hello link Linkous in are you hello
donuts 700 which heroes counter brigita
the best asked Alex Mason I think we
said maybe junk rat or a Farah would say
maybe like Hanzo Hanzo and Widow
sometimes because I think I think it was
said that she her head has a larger
hitbox and other healers oh really yeah
yeah she's kind of bulky remember when
the Hanzo arrows used to like not hit
the head but like right next to it it's
still head shot oh yeah a long time dog
yes we also check out the twitch chat
welcome welcome welcome some people were
saying tracer a lot of people saying
junk rat t-bones gonna go play alright
enjoy yourself have fun hopefully you
get a chance to play Brigitta
see you like I think I think Brigitta is
really good as a as a secondary healer
like being especially on defense being
the only one is gonna be really hard
when you have stuff flying in like this
you're the whole team taking damage and
you really can't heal them that quickly
oh [ __ ] just like that that's not right
to go in and melee to heal them and then
you get the spurt churches watching in
school I don't want to know about that
hopefully you're on just like study hour
or like this is it reach high lunchtime
wrench time what's up vape how you doing
brown t wigs i or brown twigs rather
hello I don't know what why I decided to
make that a male name and it's hello
room o said anyone with range
yeah range is I guess this was kind of
scary
one-on-one oh yeah I think like her her
charge can stop Reinhardt but not doofus
oh good block broke my shield how dare
you Oh Maura Oh get out of here McCree
like it I can probably stop that I tried
oh you're still alive Maura be Oh see
you're Reinhart well played
that's when you need the wealth well
played how did you pronounce her name
Brigitta Lee keeps it it's I want to get
into that and Brigitta it's something
like yes basically like what this I
think Vegeta well I think it the the I
sound isn't not like a G and some people
are saying like that E is not really an
e it's like an AA Brigitta yeah like a
weird like sorry
yeah it's kind of subtle like the the
change the differences
she also combos well with Ryan Hart yeah
make sense
they gotta want to be both in the action
there hi crazy commentating maybe huh
what's up Jack wine are you doing I
should come to console yet Tim dragger
ask yes she is out on console for all
those asking ps4 and Xbox one if you're
not seeing the update reset your actual
console oh no good didn't hurt never
lost anything
I'll get slapped
Oh
get rekt yeah watch your toes
FG seat yeah for there were you at are
they gonna alt like that just try to run
in remember guys there is delay so
sometimes I'm catching up on chat and
sometimes my answers don't come the
moment you ask so just be wheels I was
like tired she is out do you know when
she's available for competitive oh
that's a good question usually it's that
it's at least like a couple weeks okay
virtual Kyle says next season oh it's
they're gonna wait till next season
umm don't know it taking virtual Kyle's
word for it because that's a long time
from now they they just recently ended
the eighth season oh boy
[Music]
Oh
Jaden says she's out okay bye guys gonna
go play brigita also don't buy a skin
save up for uprising like you said I
think it's fine
also we usually are fortunate enough to
be able to buy boxes so you know I like
this team I can't read that aggressive
Steven Lee hey guys can you show her
skins after the match if you can
possibly we showed a bunch of skins
earlier can always DVR back to the like
the beginning of the stream if you want
that's when we showed them all but we
might be able to show that by the after
this match or we'll show it at the end
of the stream for sure which not there
yet but Oh getting getting close to
winding down but not well might play
another magic teeth supreme leader snoke
oh how are you still alive
but anyway it's not so far out of ten
how good do you think she is I guess
this would be based off his limited
sample size but what do you think I like
her like maybe it's just because I like
playing Reinhardt I like melee stuff a
whole lot and also healing like I think
they're doing a really good job at kind
of pushing people towards you know
healing for because I feel like supports
are the the one class that's not really
like fully fleshed out or they don't
they don't always have the options that
people want I think I heard tire butter
exploded killed nobody
what does our ultimate do asked a 2003
it basically gives her more shield and
everyone around her more shield and it
kind of keeps ticking up it's not like a
one-time thing with like lucio where
like you know it's it's just kind of
like he drops the beat and then that's
it
Allen pears I don't know if you want to
swap to we get to as your main instead
of Genji I don't know if you're trolling
me I feel like kind of you are what's up
Simon
rally to may his his life is great I
don't know if there's a man here we go
he's dead there's Makris somewhere brown
suede says is she easy to play and what
character is she most like control play
wise so kind of Ryan Hardy all right I
guess pretty much like skillshots well
the charge is like the same thing
yeah yeah right so it's pretty much like
a Ryan Hart Oh what you got I got
punched I got punched into something
into Reinhardt yeah right in front of
Reinhardt shield lemon army says I liked
and stuff thank you thank you for that
all right if you guys want to hang out
with us more frequently we stream every
day at 11:00
if you haven't stopped already obviously
hit that sub button so you know when we
go live
oh wow that tire did nothing it's the
end here it's probably all I got I got I
got an old on deck no maybe you can get
a road hog there he just wore it up into
the air
this is you road hog and um where was
there for a second Oh Junkers gonna die
here though oh oh what the oh your gears
are good I think
oh no stay behind okay oh it's okay just
Oh nineteen life
no problem he'd a nice good hold solid
hold there tried to pronounce my name
it's my real name I'm Dutch all right
Milan huizinga she's again
who's the man whose anger sorry I
probably butchered you laughing probably
pretty close on the first name though
mainly because I watch hockey and it's
easy to say like Milan mahalik or Milan
Lucic who I don't like by the way yes so
as as you melee the enemy team you are
healing yourself and your teammates
around you as well as the yeah right
yeah yeah okay sorry I thought that I
was like I was saying something wrong
and then also the other ability whoa
kick throw the flail outs and knock
people back that also counts as part of
the Viki oh don't let him get that oh
that's okay what's he gonna do give you
that yeah from downtown
Oh wha bode oh wait this is good this is
good this is exciting as brigita good
yeah I think she's pretty solid um I'm
interested to see how she gets working
in a competitive play Oh butcher skin
right there I bought that one yeah I got
that 100% it was too sick to not buy for
me personally
is her she'll whoops like Reinhardt's in
that it is ineffective against
characters like Mario yes rez the alts
from Laura still goes through I can't
heal you
oh I like interrupted all that thing did
not push him back oh you're still alive
now somehow not anymore
okay you're gonna have to make another
solid hold here runs too late please
he's getting the healer away though in a
way and I have another oh I hear it's a
tire oh no check out to people all right
you and doofus and Maura versus their
whole team I feel good about this I
really do
oh you're doing this assaulting but not
where they're at okay Oh tire yep we're
good Oh race it alright just a reinhardt
here oh that was great three alts there
to kind of like hold the line yeah and
then the rest of the team was able to
spawn get back let's see come on I don't
think it's gonna be you I mean everyone
was kind of yeah kind of contributing
pretty well seems like Moyer is still
pretty good
Pochiro made his live dude she's she's
still like really really great like that
just probably in Elliott at the very
least in quick play she's probably
number one healer down there though but
she held she helped hold there at the
end
she is so versatile lemon army what's up
gave you a shout-out earlier but give
you another one that's fine let's see
how are we doing on time I think you can
I think in play one more it's a weird
man because as we keep going the
viewership keeps going up it's fine with
me you know longer tail you need to ramp
up you know so thank you everyone for
tuning in preciate it
I'm Eric that's Joey he's playing I'm
just range at so you guys have
maybe look at the skins while your your
thingy so we're going through some
carbon-fiber one Karbala guy will show
you one at a time it's like a tease
so yeah clothes suck uh razz six never
stops as Bob Jones and time dog Restless
is asking if we think we'll see Brigitta
in overwatch League I think it'll take
some time
yeah I think the the way the meta and
the the whoa okay here's my question as
a over we over 104 watch League novice
as I don't watch as frequently as you
were some of the people in chat yeah
watch are they do they play the latest
version or they on a version and then
they move on to them so every time it's
like pash or if there's like a big
change that goes through they always
wait till the end of the stage so that's
like six weeks or so so how close are we
to the next I think I think we're maybe
two or three weeks in to this stage so
we got like another like about little
less than a month left very possible
because that first stage was all like
mercy and now it's all Moira luciana
yeah so I wouldn't be shocked if you did
see her next season because they'll have
like time you know obviously they'll be
playing this this here oh yeah
in the coming weeks you know not
practicing yeah yeah because she and
then test her viability right like
because you don't want to just like
start going to one of your like matches
that count and then not be as yeah like
and then you need to know how to powder
her yeah other team uses her so I
wouldn't be shocked to see her but yeah
definitely gonna take a couple weeks as
Joey mentioned for it her to even be
like probably usable or like understood
yeah yeah so wat see time want to tell
CJ fan man kind of want get back into
this game what do you been playing CJ
would you get off of after monster
hunter how long have you guys been
dating says hype 10 not long enough not
long enough
I know Joey is actually married
lifestyle player this is a stupid
question but what's the difference
between paladins and overwatch I
actually haven't played very much
paladins I just know paladin's came out
after overwatch
so I heard there's similarities for sure
and some characters that are whole a
dream or two don't overextend you guys
come on yeah have you played much
paladin's no I haven't played at all
well we got mercy here would you marry
Brigitta hard to say I don't know I'd
have to get to know her better
oh do you oh that got eaten so quickly
but your shield up oh gotta protect it
Godfather here if you didn't know right
now you see you get out here uh oh he
does Godfather and your Oh care again
trying to just use that machine gun
action oh yeah that's true Joey's wife
has done art for overwatch yes pretty
cool pretty awesome she has the uh she's
done some of the sprays here I don't
think I'll Brigitta does that one but
yeah the sprays from the the last the
last big update the cosmetics a little
bit of permit I love they do a little
Skyrim nice okay so a little smattering
of different things get out of here we
get that all right how are we gonna do
this
what's up Kyrie wait for the molten core
what's our alt like a CGS Wow
no no teleporting here she basically
like you gives off like an armor or
essentially that everyone that's around
her or near her will get buff oh not see
the free up there I wasn't it's a he's
about to show you what though
Tommy TM no this is live servers it's on
console on PC its console yeah I said
right I was gonna take PC whatever so
yeah you should probably get in your
last minute questions or comments or
whatever as already be wrapping up after
this match yeah is somewhat similar to
Lucy O's you know it affects like a
circle around her except it's constant
yeah so it just keeps giving you are
more every second for like 10 seconds or
so and so even if you get hit by
something they'll still build that back
up to like a maximum of 150
[Music]
died another achievement go alright well
the team needs to push with you guys
which they're not alright okay we got we
got a summer on there okay Winston's
going in OHS in the auto with the
counter he'll hear oh I'm gonna knock
them off oh no he's not going there ya
see ya
oh now you're good you can't do enough
damage oh yeah like I think every McCree
that I've run into has just bought a
good that turn is in such a good spot
it's okay they're not behind Reaper
engines do not yeah that rookies is
gonna die right
oh and not yet I had some pretty solid
matches so far here
okay you have it have another alt it's
good
yeah her all seems to come up pretty
quickly if you can survive oh you can't
get stunned here oh here i jinxed it
I thought you're gonna destroy him oh
wow comes in Yolo high noon Oh dad's
back Kerrigan quick sleeping point
Omar girl no they're the ones that keep
getting in there to deny far enough
that's why I'm very nice character super
a lioness as nerf preheat there what's
up mr. nice evil how are you doing are
you sure did you have this hurry
oh you have thing again which is insane
that mace okay look at me trading I'm
retrieving sorry guys that fire NBA Jam
oh oh here we go got a brigita duel here
one on one will win looks like him no
yeah no yet home I haven't gold damaged
by the way yeah I know I know who raised
me yeah that'd be nice it just keeps
going up Joey like little by little I
keep setting a threshold number in my
head like oh yeah we're gonna stop no no
we're not gonna stop well see how this
match goes oh you okay it's a rescue
team hold on yeah bolts
she's almost dead
[Music]
sniper Oh revival thing mercy be careful
there's a turret behind us where nirvana
wooden burg we showed this games earlier
in the stream if you want to scrub back
DVR you'll see them we'll try to show
them at the very end of the stream as
well so whoops so to get for scratching
your head there no I'll put it on my
headphones
okay and all the time the literally
isn't a fan of overwatch not sure why
he's in here to watch him all that stuff
but thanks for stopping by later does
their shield feel effective at all as
sorry I can't read your name because I
think it's in Korean yeah she feels fine
it's it's definitely not you know like
nearly as good as right yeah it's all
some things that you want to like stay
behind if you're like a teammate
oh no mercy but you also need to use it
to get the shield bash off yeah so it's
like it's more of like a personal shield
than anything else that helped that yeah
as a guy Anderson her ultimate is
basically like kind of like Lucio's
except it just keeps happening it's not
as much shield but it kind of constantly
ticks up as long as you're there near
you as long as your teammates are near
you they'll get the benefit of the
shield which you will probably do soon
or soon early like right now image so
now you can see his armors going up as
well as his teammates although you
probably can't see it as well okay he
just says let's get on the point here
pinata using his all to escape
oh this is not good mercy still alive
no it's still turret time for an all
shields chat someone tried that earlier
Alex Pollock please refrain from
promoting self-promoting would that be
much appreciated thanking killer Aloha
says she's very strong
oh mercy please be careful
well we gotta do something about that
turret he is tor Barons daughter she is
Reinhardt's goddaughter
I like it like kind of like weaving in
and out yeah I don't like get the damage
but also get the heels off oh look at me
I'm just like be able to get one last
push here at 13 seconds I maybe if we go
fast doesn't break you to his cloth on
her waist remind you what Titans mark of
Destiny a little bit actually her
character in general just reminds me of
a crusader from Diablo 3
you know why you got banned Eduardo you
probably business family the same
question that I'm not gonna read so
there's that or time down maybe what's
your opinion on her some ask geckos what
are your opinions Joey I like her I
really do alright we're gonna go to one
which is one more match one more match
okay that's I'm calling it after that
though I want you to go out on a win I
feel like last game was probably the
time stop cousin gonna get better than
that but then you know I got you I
wouldn't say I got you baited but yeah
oh we got a box for I guess you can show
skins to in between you can open the box
later what's in the box
boom oh the legendary I don't have this
one guess not
at least I got to see it before it
changed Oh got it we fast now that's
that's like the worst thing when you
when you open the box there's a
legendary or maybe even two in the air
and then right when it's about to land
cuts to like your this screen right here
I'm glad overwatch since of doom they do
fist came out and now that I moved to a
PC would it be worth getting I mean dog
oh if you enjoy playing the game and
want to try it on another platform
assuming you weren't playing on PC
before then you know this is a very good
platform for the game favorite map s
donut oh I really like Dorado and route
66 and then Blizzard world is probably
is a poser roll only from the aesthetic
point of view look at this is so cool go
to the water and there's all this other
stuff here that you can't access make it
to merlok island so well the next
overwatch event be the anniversary one
is uprising was that animal pricing was
no it was like in spring time yeah so
it's right bore yeah so I think if we're
getting anything you'd be uprising
before anniversary right yeah it could
be some time like end of this month or
like beginning of next month or
something ah
Benj I want to say Oh watches for TMC
4:30 sometimes I have sales yeah it's
go to the store oh wait I saw a 3088
somewhere though standard edition $39.99
Game of the Year Edition 59.99 I think
there's some deals to get it for cheaper
than that you just have to look around
Hansa use your scattershot while you can
they go this way okay
first name last name I know that joke
that's an office joke what a shield what
up dog there you got me oh that I'm RR
says I like was a rolled a lot because
it gives me so much nostalgia from wow
yeah I mean like I haven't even looked
all around to explore all the stuff
that's in it but yeah there's a lot of
cool stuff I like all the posters I even
like how the directories like like you
know semi like an in Disney video dude
true from here I feel like I've said
this before on like either the blizzard
World streams or any time I see it but I
honestly would pay to go to a blizzard
why I know I mean aren't they isn't like
somewhere in China making like a
knockoff blizzard well yeah I thought I
heard something about that I want the
real one
we're like or maybe it's not blizzard
just warcraft uh s Swan gaming yeah you
make a good point she's like a tank
which is also supportive she's hybrid
she's like a hybrid teleport it's the
easiest way to explain that one Oh John
cries she's going in
who took that for you
you have will counter hers with yours me
some GPS to help though nice Oh see you
later Hanzo of Genji I was getting my
bed so plays yeah always having fun
playing every detail for sure
I think it's do you like melee
characters cuz you know that's gonna be
a focus one of her focuses we got a
mercy thankfully yeah if I was solo
healing this would be tough yeah I know
Enver n coma says yeah real lifeless
world would be amazing yeah I mean like
think about all the people that just go
to Blizzcon right like I don't know
maybe it's not as much as I think it is
maybe they've thought about this and the
reason why they haven't done it yet is
because it maybe isn't viable but I
would go but yeah I guess they don't
have an I don't know it's tough but
Disney has so many like movies and
things like that yeah for like to get
different people that like different
series and things like that to come to
Disneyland
I know Marvel and now they won't Fox
right did that happen yeah I think so
they own everything okay like it's
actually a little scary it's like a
monopoly like at this point I don't know
what they don't own yeah
they don't know and CBS know yeah Karl
Avery says she won't be comp
playable till May I'm guessing that's
the next season perhaps Oh what where
was it so what do you guys feel the best
way to play her I mean you pretty much
want to be in the action because you
need it you need to melee the feel yeah
well I kind of like going in getting
hits in coming back out yeah and like
finding teammates to heal throwing the
armor packs on them yeah that's Joey I'm
Eric
snapIt Lord feels that Brigitta is you
know the overpowered in calm seas and I
don't know it's hard to say I mean like
I think she has like counters definitely
oh just just do it just like that that
guy died oh that means his alts out
that's good but I mean she feels a lot
more active than some of the other
healers like like mercy well you have to
wear your name back yeah like if you
like playing Reinhardt you'll definitely
have fun with everything just like
jumping in front of people with your
shield I doubt this is gonna be
backwards compatible ever PSP d40
backwards compatible as you like to ps3
or older consoles oh you have a better
chance hoping for switch than you do
yeah an older generation or console so
and even that I don't even know if that
would ever happen but oh yes this is
good this is good you can't reflect that
damn you other Brigitta we're swaggin
heal you you're like yeah like the only
thing you like her armor pack does have
like a 6 second cooldown so you need to
be like careful with using it sometimes
cuz if you're not near anyone and then
people start getting taking damage kind
of a mess oh like that I mean I don't
think that's necessarily wrong to play
play brigita as like kind of like a tank
like Reinhard cuz again you're gonna be
either in the backline supporting your
other support to keep like you know the
Ganges and whatnot away or you're gonna
be kind of more you know on the payload
near the payload oh yeah it's hard to
say though I mean she just came out to
live servers she's gonna be available on
console for the first time so it'd be
interesting to see what you know even
the pros do with her you know
Oh was it a tire oh that's why you're
running there like I'm not see everyone
running out
I've tried to save them yeah cheetah yes
it is on console oh thank you would you
recommend playing her on console or PC
yeah I think she will play final both
because she's a melee character there's
less oh did we all just you guys are
gonna see this in a second Wow that's
kind of cool I kind of feel bad for that
diva though oh yeah I like it
you wanted to keep the streak alive so
you tried to tried to use a super mercy
was just not around to heal that's crazy
though she pretty much was tanking four
of you guys there yeah wow that's done
that's like I feel it's compared to a
lot of the other stunts so we have like
reinhardt if he if he pinned someone or
doing this if he punches someone this is
a lot quicker yeah it's super quick it's
like it's like McCree just like right in
front of you so she's definitely gonna
be very viable I'm console I feel like B
just because the nature of her character
is like even easier to play on on
console
yeah since she is melee she doesn't
require as much Amy yeah exactly and you
want to be you know using can I
interrupt this if I missed it and you
can hit them yeah I mean are you pretty
saving stuff oh why would you come in
Genji I like that you tried there you go
right into a trap
nice yeah come on give it to him come on
I think if you had killed every detail
you would have yeah probably but dude I
think that the NIH's should be enough to
get it for you I don't know if that
counts low all right
no oh it's this guy come on damn you
junk rat if is he a like a triple here
he was going ham like all around
look at this skill yo this much skill
sure sure I don't know I thought I
thought we had play the game there I got
17 defensive assists I'll go with you
should just vote for yourself oh you
want to go through skins real quick yeah
let's do that we're gonna we're gonna
end the stream with looking through all
the skins
it's flashbang but arguably better
because she's so defensive she won't die
in the front lines you know all right so
you got classic got the ironclad he
doesn't one sees purchase epic which is
like Torian right here yeah I like that
one a lot for 250 money it does look
like a Titan mark for those asking it
totally looks like Titan work looks cool
and then here's the the white version of
that this is more like your World of
Warcraft years of the store I'm kind of
colored by the white and gold and a
little bit of purple yeah see she has a
blue one here Green Green Ranger purple
or you show some type of magenta it's
very closer to purple PSP d40 games are
challenged all they try and do a 24 hour
livestream we've done that before I
haven't done in a long time though I we
still do the extra life streams every
year yeah that was like over WI zero so
we did over 24 for sure though from the
US but we had multiple people so I don't
know if anyone at any point was ever on
for like a week so there's a that we yep
and then in the last two last two
engineer and mechanic oh she has a
little wrench here I didn't see that
yeah I don't care all right you know
what they were saying though that one
looks more like Winry from Full Metal
Alchemist anime I don't know
here watch I'll pull up an image you can
show the highlight intros for the time
being I guess or whatever else you want
the weapons her weapons aren't too
different well the soul the soul and the
monument are pretty good engineer and
engineer mechanic and weapons are pretty
close to what her regular one looks like
so your highlight intros this one I got
rally to me Oh even her ain't realized
her shield has the the Sun and the moon
on there yeah oh right on that cuz
that's the other way of lying right no
for these ones oh okay because that's
the name of the skin son and I'm
assuming monies moon because the other
ones soul there you go all explained mmm
why can't I just pull this up see
hopefully this doesn't break anything it
may or may not oh I didn't save it
okay so if you go back after you're done
with that I can go to yoga Kanak yeah
what engineer yeah
so that's Winry for a full minute
alchemist and she's like a blacksmith
that's pretty close yeah just like the
same bandanna
she got a wrench she well I don't know
breeki ties what she has it orangie hair
but yeah anyways yeah that's like more
red I got rid of it
alrighty thank you all for tuning in
we'll be back tomorrow with another live
stream 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
so come check it out
Joey's got potato mode Kingdom Come
deliverance on Friday
who's Friday and then he has the hero
guy for vaquita if you want to learn
kind of like a little bit more CH how to
play her and like what she's good at etc
etc that's on YouTube and GameSpot as
well and of course you have a bunch of
GDC stuff happening this week trying to
think about forgetting anything it's
just been a heck of a week there's a lot
of stuff going on log going on so if you
want to yesterday we played pub G on
mobile that was a thing it's free you
can download that too but yeah come back
hang out with us we appreciate it I
thank you all for tuning in don't forget
to hit that subscribe button that follow
button if you haven't already
any last words Joey nope I got nothing
alright great see y'all later peace out
see ya